if you watch president Trump's daily
briefings you might think everything
will immediately go back to normal when
social distancing is no longer necessary
and you will see our economy skyrocket
but Congress's own budget office thinks
things will be pretty bleak for much
longer at the beginning of April the CBO
released a report that predicts nine
percent unemployment at the end of 2021
this past March it was 4.4 percent was
7.1 million people out of work so that
nine percent at the end of 2021 would
mean about 15 million people could still
be out of work that's the same amount as
the peak of the Great Recession in 2009
we've already seen 22 million people
file for unemployment in this four week
period and that number is the likely to
climb higher as more and more Americans
continue to be told to stay inside in
its projection CBO assumed the US would
have 12% unemployment for the second
quarter of this year it also factored in
major physical distancing measures
continuing for the next three months and
some form of physical distancing
continuing through the end of the year
the model believes that job and business
losses will be felt for much longer than
that we're gonna take a look at the
unemployment rate of a few past
recessions and pandemics to show just
how long the US recovery might take and
why the CBO is likely right unemployment
is not a perfect metric but it does give
a good understanding of how the
workforce is faring and the economy
overall
let's start with the Great Recession the
most recent economic disaster still
pretty fresh in people's minds watch how
long it takes about 18 months to go from
5 percent to 10 percent unemployment it
peaks in October 2009 and hovers there
for another six months or so then takes
more than six years to get back under
five percent which is still slightly
above what economists consider the high
end for full employment and if you look
at the chart you can see the last time
it was under 5% was February 2008 so it
took a full eight years to get back
under that 5% this was a complete
unraveling of the US financial industry
not a global pandemic so let's add one
of those we're going to go with the 1957
influenza pandemic it matches the
severity of the koban nineteen
coronavirus with an estimated 1.1
million people dying around
world now this was a new flu virus but
thanks to monitoring and early
preparation the u.s. modified an
existing flu vaccine and was ready when
it hit however despite the
implementation of some physical
distancing measures the flu still killed
70,000 Americans though it is believed
it would have killed many more if not
for the vaccine keep in mind this was
more than 60 years ago and the overall
economy looked much different than it
does now well start with August of 1957
when unemployment was 4.1 percent it
hits a peak of seven and a half percent
in July of the following year dances
with 5 percent right here in June of
1959 but doesn't steadily fall below 5
percent until 1965 in fact we don't see
4.1 percent until November of that year
more than eight years after our initial
reading so there are a lot of other
factors that contributed to the
unemployment around this time but what's
notable is that there's barely a
recovery from our 1957 recession before
there's another one during 1960 and 61
which you can see takes a few years to
recover from it's an important lesson to
note recession recoveries can be very
short and followed by another recession
now let's look at a disease that we
didn't have a vaccine for the 1918
pandemic it's the most severe pandemic
in recent history killing about 50
million people around the world and 675
thousand in the US this was pre monthly
unemployment data but we do have annual
numbers provided by the US Census Bureau
1.4 percent in 1918 1.4 percent in 1919
but then we hit 5.2 in 1920 11.7 in 1921
6.7 in 1922 and finally in 1923 were
back down to 2.4 percent now there was a
lot more going on here than just the
pandemic troops returning from World War
one created a huge surge in the labor
force the Fed raised interest rates and
President Woodrow Wilson was slow to
respond to the economic downturn but
again we hit a period of high
unemployment that took a couple years to
come back down from let's quickly add
one more line to our chart the Great
Depression it's the one we all learn
about in history class so let's start in
1929 at 3.2 percent
watch at peak in 1933 at 25 point two
percent and finally nine years later in
nineteen
- it drops under the 5% line at 4.7% now
this wasn't a pandemic nor is it very
recent but it does have the highest rate
of unemployment at 25 percent we don't
know what the exact level of
unemployment is right now
but again in the four weeks leading up
to April 9th about 22 million people
filed for unemployment and in that same
time more states continue to issue
stay-at-home guidance for their
residents former Fed chair Janet Yellen
says we might already be at 13% and
climbing higher James Bullard the
president of the st. Louis Federal
Reserve recently told Bloomberg he
predicts unemployment to hit 30 percent
in the second quarter which we're in
right now looking at this graph it's
tough to imagine 13 percent unemployment
shooting down to under 5 percent in the
span of a few weeks it's even harder to
imagine when starting at 30% now
Washington has attempted to soften the
blow of what's going on but not everyone
is getting helped tipped workers and gig
workers may not qualify the extra $600
program is set to last only four months
Secretary of Labor Eugene Scalia is
being criticized for attempting to limit
some of the new relief programs and
we're now seeing mile-long lines for
food banks the coronavirus isn't going
anywhere and with an approved vaccine at
least a year away it's likely physical
distancing measures are staying put and
even if those measures are relaxed soon
it's unlikely that every job will be
immediately available Denmark was fast
to implement safety measures and as a
result had relatively few cases the
country is considering easing some of
the restrictions but the Prime Minister
has cautioned against opening up too
quickly
saying if we open Denmark too quickly
again we risk that infections rise too
sharply and then we have to close down
again China has been dealing with an
outbreak since January it reopened a few
movie theaters in late March and closed
them four days later it slowly started
to get manufacturing back up and running
but factories have had to implement
social distancing measures monitor
workers for possible infection and even
have groups of employees who work
together also live and travel together
which doesn't sound feasible here in the
US those limited approaches make sense
while Trump originally wanted to lift
social distancing guidelines on Easter
he has now pushed that back to the end
of april however a new report predicts a
summer spike in cove at 19 cases if
us physical distancing guidelines are
completely lifted in early May the u.s.
still doesn't have widespread testing or
containment measures for what comes
after shelter in place will people want
to risk going out to eat at crowded
restaurants back into Wrigley to catch a
Cubs game get on a crowded flight for a
vacation even hop on a packed train to
commute to work probably not and when
you multiply that across entire
industries restaurants travel
hospitality events that's millions of
employees who won't be going back to
work until this is more under control
and that's going to pose big problems in
getting the economy to take off like a
rocket